I definitely think the world needs like
bullying
people being offensive because if you
ask anyone that's actually successful
they'll tell you the reason for their
successes is their most negative parts
of their life within doesn't teach
anybody anything when you lose it
motivates you to win like now in school
they're doing like no first second third
place in school you know school um
Sports days you're not teaching children
to win like the guy who's the fastest
doesn't feel special now because a guy
who's the slowest got the same medal as
him you should know that he's the
slowest so there's a gap that now
everything's kind of all Blurred Lines
there's no definitive kind of clear
winner and everybody wants to be the
winner but they don't actually have the
ability all the skills to be the winner
so it's like you need somebody to come
and ruffle feathers a little bit in the
military that's what they do they break
you down I was in the military for six
years and they literally they break you
down they they